(audience clapping)
Hello,
hello, so nice to be here, Drew.
You look so beautiful
'Cause I'm wearing your beautiful,
empowered, gorgeous
No, because you're wearing
your heart outside.
That's why.
I do wear my heart outside my sleeve,
and I just feel so lucky to be kicking off
International Women's Day with you.
And you created the DVF Awards in 2010
to recognize extraordinary women.
What motivated you to start doing this
amongst all the other things you were doing
but really focus it in an award ceremony?
Well, it's my son.
He said, "The family foundation
since you care so much about women
you should organize an award
so that we can donate money, give support, and exposure
to these extraordinary women that people don't know."
And I know you have a guest today that reflects
exactly that.
That's exactly right.
In 2014, a woman named Veronika Scott was honored
with the DVF Award
and she's been paying it forward ever since.
And she's actually here right now
Veronica, hello?
(audience clapping)
Hello, thank you for inviting me.
Hi, Veronika.
Hi.
I knew Veronika when she was just a little girl
and Veronika is a wonderful example for me.
And we've stayed in touch and we are friends,
right Veronika?
Yes, I have to say that first night I met you.
It was like floating.
I couldn't believe it was really happening.
And you know,
that was like the first big recognition,
I had gotten
but also Empowerment Plan had ever received.
So this was huge for the organization and for me,
and it's, I'm just lucky to have your presence in my life.
And Veronika, what have you been doing
since you became a recipient of the DVF Award?
Oh man, since then, we've grown quite a bit,
I was 22.
I'm a little bit older now.
It was an interesting story of how Empowerment Plan began
as a class project of mine in college.
So I was studying industrial design
and I designed the coat while I was in school
and really designing it for people that have been displaced
and on the streets for years.
And I created it because it's something,
an opportunity with my own family had been given.
I grew up in a situation of poverty
and my parents struggled with unemployment and addiction
and mental health and creating that opportunity,
I wish could have been given to me in my family growing up.
And so since the DVF Awards,
we've distributed about 50,000 coats across the entire US
and now 21 other countries.
But you see Veronika survived it,
she really used is,
her grandfather at one point, who spoke to her
and say, "Own it girl,
unless you get educated, you're not going anywhere,
this is where your life will be."
And so from that moment on, she went to school
she made it her class project to create this code
which is more than a code.
It's a home,
because it was made for homeless.
So it's a code, that's a home.
And while she was doing that
she also gave work to homeless people to make the code.
So she really went around by her own
which is what the mission of this award is about.
(audience clapping)
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
And I appreciate that.
And it's so, I'm so lucky.
I don't think we all realize how lucky we are
that I had my grandfather that could do that.
That could sit me down.
And then I have incredible people like Diane right here
endorsing the organization and the women that we serve.
Well, Veronika,
do you have any advice like your grandfather gave to you
of where someone can start
if they would like to find that luck
and innovation for themselves?
That's a really good question.
And I think I see a lot of people waiting
for the perfect situation, waiting for something to happen.
And I think
at this point you just can't wait, you can start.
There is no perfect time,
frankly, the sooner you get out there and start doing it
the quicker you can learn.
And I've learned so much
from the community that we work with.
We would not have empowerment plan without them
and without their incredible ideas.
And I also would like to say one thing sometimes,
you are in front of a situation and it's so dark.
It's so many people you say,
"There's nothing that I could do that can save it
because the situation is so badly."
The truth is that all you need to do is save one person.
You save one person and there's a whole dynasty behind.
I am so glad that I asked both of you
because those were very hopeful answers.
And we, here at the show,
would love to support every effort
that you're making Veronika
and just donate $5,000 to the Empowerment Plan.
(audience clapping)
Oh,
Thank you so much
That's incredible, thank you.
(audience clapping)
And I will match it.
Oh yeah, yes.
Thank you,
this is amazing,
best Zoom call I've had.
(audience laughing)
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, for this inspired talk
and for more information about the Empowerment Plan
and how you can help support
go to our website @thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
and we'll shoot it to di Diane's website.
And we'll just lead you and guide you
to the work that Diane and Veronika are doing.
So thank you guys for your time.
(upbeat music)